let's now actually apply Newton's law of
cooling so just to remind ourselves if
capital T is the temperature of
something in Celsius degrees and
lowercase T is time in minutes we can
say that the rate of change the rate of
change of our temperature with respect
to time is going to be proportional and
I'll write a negative K right over here
if we assumed our constant K is positive
then a negative K it's going to be
proportional to the difference between
the temperature of our thing and the
ambient temperature in the room and once
again why I'd have a negative there well
because if the temperature of our thing
is larger than the temperature of the
room we would expect that we would be
decreasing in temperature that we would
have a negative rate of change that set
temperature should be decreasing with
time if on the other hand our
temperature is lower than the ambient
temperature of the room then this thing
is going to be negative but we would
want a positive rate of change of
temperature things would be warming up
and so that's why a negative of a
negative would give you the positive so
this right over here this differential
equation we already saw it in the
previous video on Newton's law of
cooling and we even saw a general
solution to that and the general
solution that I care about because we're
now going to deal with the scenario
where we're putting something warm in a
orce we're going to put a warm bowl of
oatmeal in a in a room temperature room
so given that we're going to assume the
case that we saw in the last video where
our temperature is greater than or equal
to the ambient temperature and in that
situation our general solution boiled
down to it boiled down to temperature as
a function of time is equal to some
constant times e to the negative KT
negative KT plus our ambient temperature
plus our ambient temperature once again
we figured this out in the last video
now let's actually apply it so I said
where we're dealing with the scenario
where our temperature is greater than or
equal to the ambient temperature so
let's assume we're in a scenario let's
assume a scenario where ambient
temperature is 20 degrees Celsius
so we assume that doesn't change that
the room is just large enough that even
if something is warmer is put into it
that the ambient temperature does not
change and let's say that the thing that
we put in it our warm bowl of oatmeal
let's say it starts off the moment we
put in the room at time equals zero is
80 degrees Celsius and let's say we also
know just from previous tests that after
two minutes after two minutes it gets to
sixty degrees Celsius so we also know
that T of two is 60 degree Celsius and
given all of this information right over
here using Newton's law of cooling and
using all of this information we know
about how bowls of oatmeal that started
at this temperature have cooled in the
past we want to know how long will it
take
how many minutes will have to pass when
you put an a degree bowl of oatmeal in
the room how many minutes have to pass
in order for it to get to 40 degrees
using this model so let me write that
down so how long how many minutes
minutes four or let me say - cool - cool
- cool
- forty degrees Celsius and so I
encourage you to pause the video now and
try to figure it out
so I'm assuming you have paused the
video and you have had your go at it and
the key is is to use all of this
information right over here to solve for
the constants C and K and then once you
know that you essentially have described
your model and then you can you can
apply it to solve for the time that gets
you to a temperature of 40 degrees
Celsius so let's do that so the first
thing we know is the ambient temperature
is 20 degrees Celsius so this right over
here this right over here is 20 degrees
and so the most obvious thing to solve
for or to apply is what what happens
with T of zero and what's neat about T
of zero when T equals zero this exponent
is 0 e to the zero power is 1 and so T
of zero is essentially going to simplify
to C plus 20 degrees let me actually
write
down so T of zero which we already know
is eighty degrees we already know is a
degree Celsius and I'm just going to
write eighty I'm just going to write
eighty we'll assume it's in degrees
Celsius that is going to be equal to
that is going to be equal to when T
equals zero this the e to the negatives
or e to the zero is just going to be one
so it's going to be equal to C plus C
plus twenty and so if you want to solve
for C you just subtract 20 from both
sides of this of this equation and we
are left with we are left with eighty
minus 20 is 60 is equal to C 60 is equal
to C so we were able to figure out C so
let's figure out let's write what we
know right now so we know that t let me
do that in that magenta color we know
that T of T and it's confusing upper
case upper case T of lower case T
temperature as a function of time is
going to be equal to is going to be
equal to them into that same color 60 e
60 e to the negative KT negative KT plus
20 plus our ambient temperature plus our
ambient temperature now we need to solve
for K and we could use this information
right over here to solve for K T of two
is equal to 60 degrees so if we make T
is equal to two this thing is going to
be sixty degrees so let me write that
down
so we could let me write it over here so
have some space so we have 60 is equal
to 60 is equal to 60 is equal to 60 e to
the negative KT all this color switching
takes time e to the negative KT plus au
and we be careful that's a time two so
that's e to the negative K times two
that's a time equals two or I could
write that e to the negative 2k e to the
negative 2k and then of course we have
our plus twenty and then we have our
plus twenty and now we just have to
solve for K
again at any point if you feel inspired
to do so I encourage you to try to solve
it on your own all right so let's do
this so if we subtract if we subtract 20
from both sides we get 40 is equal to is
equal to 60 e e to the negative 2k
negative 2k and DeVoe divide both sides
by 60 you are left with you are left
with two thirds 40 divided by 60 is 2/3
is equal to e to the negative 2k e to
the negative 2k negative 2k all this
color changing it takes work let me know
if you all want me to keep changing I
enjoy changing colors it just keeps it
interesting on the screen but anyway so
e to the negative 2k and actually let me
scroll down a little bit so I have some
more real estate to work with and now I
could take let's see I could take the
natural log of both sides and so I'll
have the natural log natural log of 2/3
is equal to the natural log of e to the
negative 2k is just going to be negative
2k that's the whole reason why I took
the natural log of both sides and then
to solve for K I divide both sides by
negative 2 I get K is equal to negative
1/2 negative 1/2 natural log natural log
of two thirds I just swap sides natural
log of two thirds let me do that since I
kept the colors going so long let me
keep it that way natural log of two
thirds and so we have solved for all of
the constants so now we can rewrite this
thing right over here we can rewrite it
as so we decided from mini drumroll here
we're not completely done yet we get T
of T is equal to is equal to 6t e e to
the negative K well negative K the
negative and negative can be positive
can be 1/2 natural log of two thirds so
1/2 natural log of two thirds negative K
so negative of a negative so 1/2 natural
log of two thirds which actually will be
a negative value two thirds is less
then II so you're going to have a
natural log of it is going to be
negative so it makes you feel good that
the temperature is going to be is going
to be going down over time and so plus
au times T times T plus 20 plus 20 and
so now all we have to do is we have to
figure out what T gets us to a
temperature of 40 degrees Celsius so
let's solve for that so if we want this
to be 40 for T is equal to it actually
now I'm just going to stick to one color
as we as we march through this part so
for T is going to be equal to 60 e to
the 1/2 natural log of two thirds t
power plus 20 now let's see we can
subtract 20 from both sides we get to 20
is equal to 60 I eat all that crazy
business 1/2 natural log of two thirds
times T now we can divide both sides by
60 and we get 1/3 20 divided by 60 is
1/3 is equal is equal to e to the one
half natural log of two thirds times T
now let's see we could take the natural
log of both sides so we get the natural
log of one-third is equal to 1/2 natural
log of two thirds times T and then
homestretch to solve for T you just
divide both sides by one half natural
log of two thirds so we get T is equal
to this which is the natural log of 1/3
divided by one half natural log of two
thirds well if you divide by one half
that's the same thing as multiplying by
two and then you're going to divide by
natural log natural log of two thirds
2/3 now let's see if this actually makes
a sensical a sensical answer so let me
get going to calculator out actually I
could just actually I could just use I
could just use Google here so I had
actually I already forgot I already
forgot what it was natural one so I have
natural log one-third over natural log
of two thirds and the whole thing times
two so I can type
I can type too
two times the natural log of natural log
of one third natural log of one third
divided by divided by the natural log of
two thirds let's see what Google gets us
all right it didn't what did I wear how
did I mess up so this is equal to two
times the natural log okay messed up the
parentheses let me make this clear the
natural log of 1/3 divided by the
natural log of two thirds and then we're
there you go if we were to round to the
nearest hundredth there would be five
point four two so five point four two
minutes remember everything we were
doing were in minutes so this right over
here this is approximately equal to five
point four to five point four two
minutes and we are done that's how long
it will take us to cool to 40 degrees